we begin in afghanistan where the
government has suffered further setbacks
in trying to hold off the advance of the
taliban the insurgents have reportedly
seized the city of ghazni near just 150
kilometers from the capital kabul u.s
intelligence reports say kabul could
come under attack within 30 days the
humanitarian crisis is deepening as tens
of thousands are seeking safety without
knowing where to turn
shaky and shocking video purports to
show taliban fighters celebrating
victory after taking a town in farah
province in the west
they appear to be dragging the body of a
killed opponent
in images too disturbing to show they
then throw the corpse into a pit
and begin shooting at it
it's scenes like that which have
prompted many afghans to leave their
rural homes and seek sanctuary in cities
like these people in a makeshift camp at
a park in kabul
tens of thousands of families have been
displaced and there's not enough food or
other relief material for them
the displaced people are in a terrible
and frustrating situation but the
government has not sent a representative
here to help
as the afghan government struggles to
contain the taliban's military advances
it's also appealing to the world
community for humanitarian support
customers
we call on the international community
and international institutions to help
as soon as possible to provide food and
non-food items to the many people
displaced in afghanistan
many have questioned the very speedy
withdrawal of u.s led international
forces which is due to be complete this
month
but criticism is also being directed at
neighboring pakistan for not using its
influence over the taliban to end the
bloodshed and rights abuses
pakistan's foreign minister shah mahmud
qureshi rejected the criticism and said
his country would play its role to
facilitate the afghan peace process and
the policy of
we have done whatever we could and we
will continue to do
what we can
for peace for stability
and for regional connectivity
it is in sync with the agenda of our
government
the return of the taliban and the
possibility of a protracted civil war
are likely to prompt an exodus of
refugees many heading west towards
europe
greece was often the first point of
arrival in the eu during the 2016
migrant crisis
athens says it's not able to handle
another such wave of arrivals
joining me now from dortmund is elenor
zaino who leads the conrad adenauer
foundation in kabul eleanor welcome we
should mention that you live in kabul
but happen to be joining us just now
from germany so i just want to ask you
first how surprised you are by the pace
of the taliban advances
well all of us we were very much
surprised how fast and successful the
taliban could capture basically all over
the country the main districts the
provincial capitals 10 provincial
capitals almost they have taken and
kabul now seems to look more and more
encircled so this was a surprise to
everybody nobody expected that
was this inevitable after joe biden
announced the withdrawal of u.s troops
well i think in the end i i think most
of the international countries they were
willing to leave everybody was saying it
was time to leave after 20 years but
what is now criticized as the way we
left so how quick the united states and
withdraw and did not ask for any further
conditions from the taliban side to at
least to to ask for conditions for the
negotiation
in in doha for the peace process so this
is criticized the way how how the nato
troops left and the united states left
biden and others have said it is up to
the afghan forces to fight for their
freedom simply put are they up to it
what we see now i mean yes everybody
says the afghans have to fight for the
country but what we see now is
surprisingly also that the afghan
security forces
seem to be inferior to the taliban who
are much more highly motivated and that
is surprising because the afghan
security forces outnumber the taliban
fighters by by about 10 times but the
reasons for this what i see is that the
taliban fighters are much higher
motivated they also suffer severe losses
but they get new recruits also from the
neighboring countries while the morale
or the morality of the afghan security
forces is going down and down after they
have lost their international security
partner and now they have hard times
finding new recruits they have i think
about 50 percent of their positions are
vacant because they cannot find any more
um recruits for their own troops
taliban forces have now just taken uh
the town of ghazni some 150 kilometers
from kabul are we jumping the gun to ask
if it is indeed possible that kabul
could also fall
yes that is this is now what we are
concerned about very much concerned and
the the fear and the concern is growing
now daily and kabul i can really feel it
also in my network in my office
how much the fear is increasing now and
now we hear yes we hear sources saying
that maybe kabul might be attacked
within a couple of weeks and this will
be a very tough battle because we know
kabul will be the last city to be
attacked but it will be a very tough and
very hard fight and this is what
everybody is now very much concerned
about
there are concerns about the safety of
afghans who help nato forces
and even international ngos and and
think tanks like yours are you concerned
at this point about your colleagues back
in kabul
yes that's our main concern in the
moment of course we are very much
worried about our local employees we
don't know how to protect them and to
keep them safe and we have been working
on crisis management now for weeks but
the last days have become more and more
intense and
more frightening for everybody
that is eleanor zyno who leads the
conrad adenauer foundation's office in
kabul really appreciate your time and
perspective
thank you
the taliban's relentless onslaught in
afghanistan is bringing them close to
taking the major city of maza isharif
this comes after the insurgents have
taken up to 10 regional capitals and are
closing in on more by one estimate the
taliban are in control of 65 percent of
afghanistan's territory mazar and its
inhabitants are cut off from the rest of
the country and are awaiting the worst
this is mazar isharif the city still has
a semblance of normal life even as the
taliban close in
mazar is the hub of the country's north
it's also afghanistan's fourth largest
city
if and when it falls to the taliban it
will be a huge prize in their quest to
take control of the country
until recently mazar hosted germany's
contingent of nato forces in afghanistan
but they're gone now part of the general
withdrawal of foreign coalition troops
people who fled fighting in the north
have brought back grim tales
the taliban are beating and robbing
people
and if there's a young girl or a widow
in a family they forcibly take them we
fled to protect our honor
afghan president ashraf ghani has paid
an emergency visit to shore up support
from local warlords
but the city's chances of surviving a
taliban onslaught are by all accounts
slim
it's largely cut off from the rest of
the region and it seems only a matter of
time before it falls
the consequences for the inhabitants
could be dire this is the city of kunduz
recently taken by taliban forces the
united nations also warns of calamitous
consequences when the taliban takes over
a city
in the areas that have already been
captured by the taliban and in contested
areas the office is receiving reports of
summary executions attacks against
current and former government officials
and their family members
military use and destruction of homes
schools and clinics and the laying of
large numbers of ieds improvised
explosive devices
mazar isharif may be enjoying its last
days or even hours of relative freedom
before residents will have to live with
the sight of taliban fighters patrolling
their own streets